Awesome.
Uh, I think, I think we're, we're starting a little
early, so I just, I just wanted to just to see if you can get
a little energy in the room,
um, and, and, you know,
myself and Janek, we have an awesome set of, uh,
slides and awesome set of demos so I could show you. We're actually
gonna build some stuff together here.
We usually don't do that in a breakout session, but I think it's
gonna be really cool.
Um, just a quick show of hands, how many of
you are developers?
Wow, that's a lot of developers. Awesome.
So that's good. That's a good part because you're gonna enjoy the
building part here.
Um, how many of you have heard
about the like the two really big transformational
launches in Lambda, this reinvent?
OK, a few hands, so I think that's gonna be useful
to a lot of developers.
Uh, how many of you are engineering leaders?
OK, lots of you are engineering leaders. Awesome,
awesome. So I think there's, there's gonna be a bit of
a mix of both things here today.
Um,
I'll introduce myself in a second. Um,
there's, there's gonna be a little bit of a mix of,
um,
lambda strategy or serverless strategy all up.
What are we trying to do?
Um, I'm gonna actually share, I, I,
I mostly speak to a lot of customers
this week.
I'll share some anecdotes about that too is, uh,
you know, every reinvent has a bit of a surprise. I think this
is my 9th reinvent, um,
so why don't we get going and I'll, I'll share my
stories with you guys and we'll, we're gonna build some cool
stuff together. So, OK,
we're talking about
the build, building the future with AWS
Serverless, and we've actually played around with the,
with the title a little bit. We're saying we were gonna talk about
the future of Serverless, but I think
one of the things we wanted to share with you
is what is our strategy, how we think people
are gonna build in the future, and why Serverless is
so key here.
Um, I'm gonna introduce, let my partner introduce
himself, when, when he comes up to do the,
the first of the demos, but I'm Osman Khalid, folks.
I'm the head of serverless compute.
Uh, I've been with AWS for almost 12.5
years, and I started my role, uh,
with a little known service called Autoscaling
and auto scaling groups, which was a precursor
and it's still the thing that powers, uh,
lambda, ECS, EKS.
Um, and I've been with the ser in the server space
with Eventbridge step functions. Uh, these
services are under me as well.
Uh, at AWS since 2018,
2019.
So it's been quite a few years with the, with the team here,
um, and still going strong, and my passion always
has been developers. I've been a developer myself. If
you were to Google my name,
you'll see I made a break dancing puzzle game
that not a lot of people bought, but, OK, it
was a great learning experience.
Uh, so I know I'm not a break dancer
in case you're wondering, um,
so. That's me,
uh, and why, why you should listen to me is basically
because this is, I'm the guy who sets
the strategy for Servius, and, and, and Jennek
and I work really well together
to work through this, and we, that's why we want to share with you. We wanted
to share with you in this for the next hour
the things we've obviously done and how they connect with
that overall strategy and what we're, where we're taking
Servius because Servius, you know, we celebrated 10 years
of lambda last year.
Um, but it really is, it's at an
inflection point, and I think
all of us,
we're all in technology, lots of developers, lots of
engineering leaders here,
we're all seeing this inflection point in technology,
kind of like what, what the Internet did in the early
2000s. I was a little too young for that, although
my gray hair speak otherwise,
um,
and, but I think with AI, and look, I'm not gonna
talk tons about AI and I'm, I'm, and I'm
still learning how to use it myself and.
And no, I don't believe it's gonna change,
you know, all our jobs, but I think it, it already is
accelerating us, so I'm gonna share some of the anecdote anecdotes
for that. So
I'm gonna set the stage
for what the strategy is and the agenda.
We have this build a challenge, so we're gonna build a few
things. Janek is gonna kick that off, and then
we'll, we're gonna talk about some of our other innovations
which were launched
a week before we invent. So you might have missed
those as well. And then we kind of recap and kind of
share with you where we're going next. That's what we're gonna
cover today. Sounds good.
Yes, nodding heads? Awesome.
Alright, so,
uh, I love this quote. Uh,
you know, I,
you know, we all the engineering leaders all here
and the engineering and the engineers themselves, you know
that changes is constant, right?
But my favorite quote at all change is about change,
and I actually found that the, who actually
said the original one is PJ O'Rourke. He's a journalist,
a US journalist, um.
And look, I already kinda signaled this to you folks.
We are going through change, right? And, and
kind of like the big takeaway for me talking to customers
at Reinvent,
especially when they, when they're talking to me about Serverless and
the future of Serverless, is really
the maybe their their old platform strategy,
the old way of doing things is just
not working time and time again when I hear
from developers, developer, development leaders,
platform leaders.
Is that
there's an even bigger struggle with the engineering
teams between the engineering and platform teams now
because the engineers just wanna try things when the
cost of trying something has
just plummeted,
you can, and I'm not talking about vibe coding, I'm talking
about real production engineering here, and that's what we do
at Lambda and then Serverless as well. We have,
and this is some of the stuff we're gonna show you
how we were able to accelerate that because
we, we use AI as a, as a tool, as an
accelerant. When things have become so
much faster, if your deployments, if your
operations, if your patching activities are
getting in the way,
if you've just kind of inverted the, the entire
SDLC, frankly,
and that's not just at AWS, multiple
customers are seeing the same thing and that's why
I had more so more, more customer
conversations this year than uh in the last few years
simply because.
You know, people are coming around and saying, yeah, we had
a community based based platform, but
like what can we do more with Servius because our developers
just wanna go faster and faster
and they don't wanna have all the liabilities
of, of managing the code.
So
really what what I'm really trying to say is that we
are at an evolutionary time. We all feel it.
I don't have to, I don't have to convince it whether
what the final stage of this is we don't know.
I certainly don't know and I'm not claiming that I know,
but we are going through an evolutionary period.
And so one of the things that, uh, as which
is a key part of our strategy at Servius, we, we
always focused on developers.
Maybe we didn't focus enough on the developer
experience, but we have, so, and we, that's a key pillar of our strategy
so far, but.
It was all about speed and evolution and
creating evolutionary architectures and I'll show you in the
architecture and what I mean by that, but if,
if, if we're living in a in a in a time and we
are where things are changing rapidly.
If your systems, your processes, your people are
able to evolve,
those are the ones that are gonna be the most successful, the companies
who actually are able to evolve and transition
are gonna be the most successful, so why not your architecture
as well? So
for I didn't check how many of you were system architects, but
I'm guessing a lot of you, a lot of the engineers are systems
designers as well. You all know that there's no such thing as the
right architecture,
right? It's only the right trade-offs,
um, witherless.
Yeah, you have a, you build highly evolutionary
architectures, but just to, so I kick
off and get into the early part of the
conversation, I'm not here to sell you anything either, so
I'll be, I'll be as balanced as possible, obviously
I'm a, I, I, I'm very passionate about the
space, but there are trade-offs
if you have a high, highly, highly evolutionary
system, you're, it's very hard to manage
change. It's very hard to observe what's
broken because things are more decoupled because, uh,
are, are, are changing very rapidly.
Um, for some of the platform team owners,
one of the things that's weighing on their mind is control.
How do I, how do I govern? How do I make
everything compliant? How do I, while, while my developers
wanna move faster and faster and faster, so yeah,
there are trade-offs that we have to manage.
But the final thing that I always tell when we have this
conversation is like look evolution is is not a new
thing in in tech like just because Gen AI
has captured the hearts and minds of so much and it
has been so disruptive for us, the
engineering community here.
Speed always has mattered in business, and
the, the fastest you are, the the more
likely you are to win.
So let's go to about the server list.
I don't know if this is the biggest secret, and Jane believes it's
the biggest secret in server list, but look, server, serverless
was always running,
you know, I, I operate a fleet of literally
hundreds of thousands of servers,
bare metal servers too, so those are extra fun
to patch and scale.
But what we've done is we've created a facade
for developers where the developers just don't
have to worry about
the, the management of the servers, management
of runtime, scaling, load balancing,
you know, request routing a lot of those
things are just taken care of
us directly.
But so while there's hundreds of thousands
of servers in our fleet and from USC1
all the way in Asia and I don't
think we have an we have an African region now too, right?
So there you go all over the planet.
But to you or the developer or to the engineering
leaders who are who've built a surveless architecture,
this is what it kind of looks like in the in this pic this
picture here
is simply me trying to play around with
an idea of like, hey, I wanna build an
agent or build an application that can guide
users during national emergencies.
So yeah I'm talking a lot of MCPs
here I'm talking to a bunch of different
uh services that are available
I think I have FEMA here etc.
What I, what I mean by evolutionary here is that
each feature, each facet of my idea is
actually one of those, those, these, these horizontal
lines you see that see that go through lambda. I'm
obviously using an,
uh, an AI, uh, I'm using Bedrock
to host my models,
but if I imagine if I in this particular architecture
I wanted to add a new feature, I, I deliberately didn't put
it on a slide. I wanted to add a notification
feature where customers can sign up to a notification
and maybe over SMS or email I can
email them notifications or SMS them.
Um, if my, my advice from my
app, for example, if the sign up, that would just be a
branch.
I'm not updating a bunch of microservices,
that is just a branch and one of the key things,
and again I know the tools are heavily evolving
even in the last 6 months that they're heavily evolving, one
of the things that I, I've seen my engineering teams
do is that smaller changes,
smaller contexts, smaller files
just are so much better, so much faster to
iterate on, and the AI is far more right.
And, uh, building those things and it is just like
one shotting, I mean white coding I think
really is a marketing term at this point, frankly,
uh, and guess what, all of these things are a single
responsibility of lambda functions and super
easy to manage and update and super
fast and, and Janek is gonna show you some of these things
when he comes and talks about it.
And look, at the end of the day when you build that architecture,
yeah, there were lots of parts to it. There's IAC
that you had to, to probably use to actually
create and manage the, the, the, the
system.
But once you have that set up,
I like to talk about the ilities.
Right, and maybe, maybe you folks have a platform
team where there's other humans who go and
manage and scale servers for you. They fixed
focus on reliability, durability,
but that's not actually true, right? Even in the platform
team case they don't know your software,
so many things that are that are that are
around like
security and, and scalability all the
way go into the software that the developers are writing
too. And if you're choosing an underlying
infrastructure technology.
Then you are responsible for those things, and if you ever
start thinking about your ideas going to global scale, you
can see how hard it gets.
And look at the heart of it,
what, what customers love
with and why they build, sorry I went too
fast, why, why customers love building with Servius
is that
those ilities that I had in the previous slide
are all managed by us.
That is kind of like the heart of Servius at the end of the
day. It's not about having those servers.
It's about having no servers to manage and no infrastructure
to manage and then expressing your logic the fastest
way possible.
OK, so speed is the key thing. I
mean, I already set that up like speed always wins
and that is our number one goal.
Our number one goal has been always
how can we be the fastest to
market? How can we take an idea
that customers have and be the fastest way
to do this? And I, I mean the funny. Anecdote I would share
with you,
uh, many years ago, I think it was 2013, 2014,
it was about a year of working on auto scaling. My
boss asked me like, Hey, what's the charter for auto scaling?
This is before lambda. This is before
ECS and Kubernetes, and I was like,
Hey, it's the fastest way
to go take an idea and take it to scale,
and the best idea, let the best ideas win. Obviously
we've come a long way from just using auto scaling
VMs now,
but, uh, this, this statement is
at least has been true for me, and as I've been
in this space of helping people move faster.
And faster because this is what matters. I think
this is the thing that that matters all
the way from what why customers adopt the cloud
all the way to how they build cloud natively
to move faster.
OK, and I wanted to share, uh, a
really quick anecdote. This is a very recent anecdote as
well the last couple of months where, um, Cyber
Arc, which is a platform
engineering, and a team in Cyber Arc, basically built
their entire platform on Serverless,
and they were able to do this, uh, the
automation work that they need to do, uh,
and, and, and basically
save something like 4 months out of the 12 months it took
them to build new services.
Um, I mean this code itself is probably 6
months old. I, I would say this number is probably much, much
lower now given the way the state of tools is.
And again, once something is written.
I mean, I think the final, final stage, I, I have
a Tesla as well, but then I unfortunately played full,
full self-driving for it, which it doesn't
do after many years,
uh, because at the end of the day it's liabilities,
uh, the last
LT is liability,
and when you serve us,
more of the responsibility is on our line
of the fence. At the end of the day, myself and engineering
teams are the ones who are responsible
for the scale
and patching and security of your applications versus
you doing so.
I mean there's still a shared responsibility, but a lot of
it is on our side of the fence.
And look, it's not a new technology
anymore, although I, as we get into the thing, I think
we've, what we've done over the last 12 months and launch,
launch and reinvent
really transforms this 10 year old technology as well,
but several this is already everywhere. I'm obviously not gonna
go through all of these things. I just wanted to kind of highlight to you
how many big names
have major applications at scale
applications running on lambda today.
OK, so let's go. Let's enough
talking about like the context of why we're here. I
think a lot of people aren't familiar with the feature,
so I wanna get into it and have, uh, introduce
my, my partner Jana Agarwal, who
will come introduce himself, and he's walk us through some
actual of some, some actual building things.
Thank you Audible.
No, Am I audible now?
All right, I'll thank Usman again.
So, hello everyone, I'm Janna Kagarwal.
I used to be a developer for around 8 years,
so my perspective on Serves has really been informed
by both sides of the equation
of being a developer,
uh, you know, whose services need to run in production,
you know, flawlessly.
And now you're trying to build tools and
services that developers can trust to run
their critical workloads on.
So, I like to still think of myself as a
good developer, but I'm probably not,
uh, but I am a product manager and
I lead uh PM for Lambda.
So,
Lambda has been around for a decade now.
And as with any product or
technology that manages to stick around for around
a decade and more,
there's some notions that build up,
there's some preconceived notions, biases
even about what the technology can do,
what it cannot do, what is it good for, what is
it not good for, and so on.
But then there's always some inflection points that come
in, and I believe, I really believe that Serveus
is at such an inflection point now.
So, what we're going to do next is we're
gonna have some fun, you know, over the next
30 minutes or so, we're going to build an
application, and along the way, I'll
show you some of the capabilities that we
launched
that allow you to now bring workloads to serverless
that you could not before.
OK. So
here is what we're going to build.
It's a note taking application, you know, it's
going to have create, read, update, delete, uh,
as functionalities.
Uh, we're gonna scale the application.
We're going to then build new features
that our customers will want encryption
and decryption of notes, analyzing the sentiment.
And finally, for those who really
like to write lengthy notes, the
generation is not,
uh, at least research says the attention
spans are going down, so we're going to use AI to
summarize our notes.
OK. So
let's move on to phase one. We're going to build our
foundation now, the CRD APIs.
And I'm not going to show you my typing speed.
What we are going to leverage here is uh
vibe coding, as Usman was talking about.
And uh a key to
uh VIP coding or successful VIP coding
is uh is a technology that we released
earlier this year. It's the serverless MCP
server. What it
enables your favorite
AI coding assistant to do
is to convert your national language
prompts better into well-architected
codes, which are uh compliant to,
you know, you can run it in production very fast.
So let us get to it.
We're gonna do it in 3 phases, OK?
So, the first is we're gonna install our MCP servers,
and my personal, personal preference is
to also install the DOC MCP server.
I found it to be really useful
in using new technologies which have been
recently announced,
and uh I love to hear, and I'm pretty sure all
of us love to hear that you are absolutely
right. Uh,
the DOC MCP server reduces it.
If you know, you know what I'm talking about,
but, uh, I, I like to use it.
In the second phase, uh, we're going to actually
write code for our CRUD APIs.
Uh, it's going to be a fully serverless architecture, so
API gateway for ingress,
lambda functions for CRD operations.
Uh, we're gonna use Dynamo DB tables for
serverless, uh, databases,
uh, cloud watch,
structured logging, you know, observability is really critical
in server-less architectures.
And I like to think that I'm still a developer, so
I like my types. I'm going to be using TypeScript
for this. And
then finally comes the build and deployment phases,
and what we will see is that the MCP
server defaults to using this tool
for build and deployment called SAM.
SAM stands for serverless application model.
We've uh purpose built it for serverless
builds and deployments.
Uh, it really simplifies your
uh builds, your deployments,
and uh also enables you, enables
you to simplify your local testing phases.
So what I've done is I installed the
serverless MCP server, and here's a
picture that shows you the tools.
At the time when I captured the picture,
around about a week before reinvent, you know, we had 25
tools. These tools are now available
for the AI coding assistant.
Some of the critical tools
are, uh, you know, it gets guidance in
what workloads are good for lambda, what are not good
for lambda,
how to build and deploy web apps, how to
build and deploy event-driven architectures,
including your Kinesis and Kafka,
ESMs and so on.
It also knows how to,
when I see tools there to get metric, you know, to
uh get metrics for cloudwatch, you know,
you have to know which metric, where to get it
from, and so on. It helps to
uh fine tune that for you.
And also assist SSE.
Next, we're going to write the code.
So, I threw in the prompt that we saw on
the previous slide,
and in around about 5 to 10 seconds,
uh, Quiro, you know, my AI assistant,
uh, it's gonna tell me that the code files
are already done, and the next step is
to build and deploy.
So I've magnified some images
here for us to examine what it did under
the hood. So you see the project
structure that uh
Quiro or my AI coding assistant made
with the help of the MCP server.
Uh, you see the template. YAML file,
you, that is the IAC assistance that
you get out of the box.
The package.JSN
enables you to simplify dependency management
for your application. The TS file is obviously
the business logic,
and the TS config
uh helps you to simplify the build or know
knows the build steps to run
as you transile the TypeScript to JavaScript.
And then there's some error handling which is now automatically
built in. So without the MCP server,
this was not built in. I don't have a before picture,
but the after picture is here.
You see there's sufficient input validation. We're
doing 3 retries when it comes to
writing to Dynamo TV, you know, good practices.
Uh, here are some additional best practices built in.
Uh, you see the global error handler
here. We have consistent
HTTP status codes,
uh, structured logging with CloudWatch, all,
you know, unavailable from the get-go in the
V0 of the code that was written automatically.
So the code generation process, you know, it's, it's
much more compliant to a well architected framework
with this. The
next step for us is to build and deploy.
So I've thrown in the command to build and deploy to my
assistant.
What it does is, you know, SAM will take over.
It will use the YAML files, the TS config
files, and the package files to
run the deployment for us.
It will enforce best practices along
the way, you know, we'll magnify this image in a bit.
It will show us the cloud formation
change stack or the change set
uh that shows the delta of
all of the
work that we're going to deploy to AWS.
It will upload the code to S3.
In a second, hopefully, that is complete. Here's the
change set,
and then as we go to the console,
we will see that our functions then
begin to light up.
The council should load any moment now.
There you go.
So, here are all of the 5 functions that
we wrote, and they're right there available
for us to sort of serve traffic to.
So, here's some uh magnified images.
So while building, you know, Sam detected
that our APIs had no authentication.
It was asking me to confirm if this is really what I
want to do
and uh since this was a demo, you know, I
chose to go yes.
Here's a snapshot of the change set
that it is walking us through. It is adding
uh all of these files, these rules and
permissions for databases and functions and so
on. So your build
and deployment steps are also much simpler
with SAM.
So if you think about it, uh, I don't know if
I spoke more than 57 minutes,
uh, but in around about 5 to 7 minutes, we
have a fully working back end and the cloud
operations, the cloud APIs are deployed
fully using natural language
with well architected framework, you know, sort of
baked in.
And when we talk to customers, you know,
they do tell us that generative AI has actually
sped up the code generation process,
but it's not resulting in shipping the
actual software faster.
That's because the ship cycle has a much more,
you know, process baked into it, you know, there's IAC,
there's code reviews, and so on,
and all of that is not really becoming
faster with Gen AI,
and that is where Survellus has tried to innovate
right across the stack.
So we enforce best practices while you
generate the code, we just saw that
during build steps and also during deployment steps.
The key takeaways I want us to sort of focus
on here are that uh MCP
server helps you to
uh generate, you know, best practices
sort of code baked in, the best practices baked into
the code. And I work
with a lot of developers.
And their productivity is high,
you know, but they are now actually able to ship software
also faster.
Because the IAC is baked in
and uh what they love the most is the
code that is produced is of a consistent quality
because a lot of people, you know, a lot of customers also
sort of complain that, hey,
uh, some people just wipe code and then send out a
code review without, you know,
making sense of what it is.
It sort of helps you to minimize those problems
by producing a code of uh consistent quality.
Alright.
So moving on,
let's say our application was picked up by
some news media outlet.
Now, what that has resulted in
is a bunch of concurrent traffic,
you know, right off the bat.
So the way customers tell us they handle this scenario
is uh they overprovision
capacity. When I say overprovision, meaning, you know, they
provision for peak
with the, with the understanding that
hey, at some point in time, you know, I'll go back in
as a developer of that application and try to optimize
my, you know, costs by
applying the right scaling policies.
But this provisioning for peak leads to higher
costs
and also a bunch of human-led maintenance.
And, you know, tomorrow never comes.
Um, the, the scaling policies, you know,
you're constantly having to optimize, but you find
ways to just build features instead of focusing on also
on optimizations.
So how do we handle that with serverless?
So with Serverless, we give you hands-free scaling
options. Our scaling rate is
pretty much
uh fastest amongst all compute
choices that you have.
So we give you 1000 execution environments
every 10 seconds.
So if you think about it, if your function's
execution time is 100 milliseconds,
what you're really getting is 10,000
RPS
every 10 seconds,
right off the bat without lifting a finger.
Let's uh
run a load test.
So, I've designed a very basic custom load
test. Uh, I'm around
about a minute in here, and you see that
I've literally 700, 800xed
the traffic in like 25, 30 seconds.
And there is not a single error, there's
not one throttle.
You know, lambda is able to just absorb it
right off the bat, and
you didn't have to lift a single finger to
do so. So this is
the power that Serveus gives you. This is
the kind of workload that Serveus really shines
in, uh, leads to a lot
of happy new users, end users,
and all of this without any idle costs.
So the key takeaways are like,
our scaling rate is really fast, you
know, fastest amongst all compute.
And let us call this type of a traffic, you
know, needlepoint traffic.
So, imagine that, you know, you're building an
application where,
uh, you know, hundreds of thousands of spectators
in the stadium have to scan a
QR code
whenever a goal is scored.
You can just, uh, you know, seamlessly handle
that. Or, you know, there's a flash
sale,
and I see a bunch of people wearing shoes of that
company, and, you know, you can,
uh,
a new shoe drops, a new flash sale
starts, you know, you can just handle that seamlessly.
And uh testing is quite simple
because you're literally only testing your
application logic. You're not testing scaling at all, it
just works. Lambda provides it to you out of the box.
And multiple pieces of the functionality
in our application,
so you, you saw we had 4 or 5 APIs
that we built,
all of them scale at the same rate independently
of each other without
affecting scaling rates of anything else. So the, the
noisy neighbor problem that you have is sort of eliminated.
And this is all
without managing any infrastructure.
Right, so far, so good.
Let's uh move on.
So, you know, we're good people, you know, we listen to our
customers,
and based on the customer feedback, we
are now building this new feature called
encrypting,
decrypting notes and analyzing, analyzing
its sentiment.
So if you think about it carefully as a
developer,
the, the profile of your workload here is
shifting.
It's no longer just CRD APIs,
uh, it is a more CPU intensive
workload.
You know, because we listen to our customers, you know, the
feature also achieves popularity.
Uh, what I mean by that is the scale
to zero aspect is no longer super
important for you.
There's always some traffic to serve, always
some users to service,
so there's always, in other words, you know, some steady-state
traffic.
And I'm loosely defining steady-state here as,
you know, with a peak to main traffic ratio of
around 2.
How do we handle that with serverless?
Well, it was hard.
So when we talk to customers,
this is what they tell us.
In this phase of the application, they really
want to drive optimizations.
They want to optimize costs,
they want to optimize performance, pro probably
by leveraging the latest in compute, memory,
network intensive instances and so on.
And they want to do all of that with a familiar
developer experience that they
currently, you know, use, they like, they
love with all of the integrations
and with fully surveillance operations, you know,
so in different words, they don't want to
remove the focus away from core business logic,
they want to continue to leverage the practices
that they use today but get more choices.
So what did they do before
this week was,
you know, we, we saw that they would just focus on
rearchitecting the solution away from
serverless,
away from lambda.
And that was an incredibly inefficient
use of engineering time.
It dilutes the focus away from business logic,
results in an increase in ongoing maintenance
costs in perpetuity,
and again, incredibly inefficient.
So we wanted to design a better way to
support such scenarios.
In serverless on lambda.
Uh, and we're delighted to introduce to you
Lambda's managed instances.
So the mental model behind this feature
is that we want to give you all of the Lambda's sim
simplicity in developer experience
and integrations and tooling.
And marry it with EC2's
specificity and flexibility of choices
and compute and network and memory that you
get. So,
with the LMI
you get access to latest,
you know, for instance, families like Graviton
4, you know, or probably Graviton
5 as soon as it comes out.
You're going to get
uh the latest generation in instances
in memory compute,
network optimized.
All of this continues to be fully managed
as Usman was saying earlier, you know, surveillance
is not the absence of
servers, you know, we just manage the servers
for you. Here we're giving you those options,
but we continue to manage the servers for you,
so we're going to continue to scale them, you know, patch
them, route requests to them, you know, the
whole thing. You
continue to get the same extensive event source integrations
that you used to get with lambda and
you still get with lambda rather.
And with this uh LMI we're also
adding a new
feature
called multi-concurrency,
or the ability to serve multiple requests
from the same execution environment, which has been a
long-standing customer ask.
And uh
when you combine this feature with EC2's
pricing incentives of savings plan,
reserved instances, and so on,
your cost really, really optimizes.
And we'll see in a second how.
So using
lambda managed instances is as
easy as just creating a capacity
provider. When you create a capacity
provider, you have the option to specify
any choice you want, and again, I, I
focus on the word option because this is
really an option,
optional setting that you specify.
Any instance types,
any scaling policies, you know, maximin, all
of that is configurable,
but optionally. You can just be hands-free
and let lambda and AWS take care of it.
Once you do that,
you will create your function the way you, uh, you do
today. You'll just configure it to a capacity provider.
And then lambda will scale it, patch it,
you know, run it, provision the instances,
uh, it will pick the suitable instances for your
workload and, and drive this continuous
optimization loop for the utilization.
Now, adding servers to server list, you
know, it's a tricky
thing to sort of get right.
So we did uh try to do deep research
here to make sure that the experience is as simple
as, as it possibly could.
Let us see how.
So, I'm on the Lambda console now, and
I head to capacity providers, the new feature
that lights up.
I'll create the capacity provider, give it a name,
give it a VPC, subnet,
security groups,
and an operator role that has
access to manipulate my EC-2,
and then I head over to the advanced settings where the action
really is.
So here you can choose your architectures,
you know, from Graviton or X86.
You can uh include or exclude certain
instance types or, you know, just let Lambda
pick for you.
You can apply scaling policies, you know, a
max to cap your costs,
or a min to always have some pre-warmed
instances available to serve your traffic.
You can tag them for tracking,
tracking purposes, and so on.
And when you head back here in a second, you'll see that
the capacity provider is now active.
Now, at this point, you know, there is no EC2
instance that has started because it's just the capacity
provider construct that you've created.
There's no charge for creating this capacity provider.
The next thing we have, we,
we thought of getting right or we just wanted to get
right was the
same developer experience that you have
with Lambda today.
Let's see how we did.
So, here's the updated create function
flow. You can see that it is the
exact same,
but there's just one new additional parameter,
which is the capacity provider config.
And along with here, I wanted to highlight two
additional features. One is the multi-concurrency
support that we've discussed in a second,
a second back.
And then there's also the ability to customize
the memory to CPU ratio.
Just like EC2 instances, you
can now choose your memory to CPU ratio
on lambda
to conform to the compute-intensive
or memory-intensive or, you know, general-purpose
instances.
So you can imagine the classes of new workloads
that you can now run on lambda, which you could not
before. So
what we'll do next is I've,
I'll throw in that create config command
to my assistant.
And I'll then create my function, I'll
go back in there,
and when I see the configuration tab,
there it is, it's configured to the capacity provider.
I'll go in, change the memory settings
to 4 GB for the function for demo purposes,
and I'll go back into that other setting in
a second, and I will shift
the
multi-concurrent setting to 64
concurrent requests from the same execution
environment, change the memory to VCPU
to 4S2 1.
And when I hit save,
and then head back to the capacity
provider, I'll see that
the function is now active.
And it is at this point that my EC2
instances will be created. Here's the EC2
console.
And uh if you notice uh carefully,
you know, the, when I provided subnets
initially while creating the capacity provider, I
provided it in 3 AZs.
So my EC2 instances are also across 3
AZs now.
So my instances and by extension,
my application
is also now finally AZ balanced.
And at this point, once the function is active, the
EC2 instances are spun up,
your execution environments are pre-warmed
with multi-concurrency support enabled,
ready to serve your traffic.
So let's start a load test with our synthetic
workload.
And uh
I'm around about 13 minutes into the load
test. I enhanced the load test tool for this.
Um, you see, the traffic is much
more steady-state. It's still increasing, but
still steady-state in, in, in our definition
here. And we see that the
scale up from 3 is now to
7.
We've achieved a utilization of around 25%.
The utilization of memory
and VCPU and the
instances, the underlying EC2 instances, utilization
is still pretty healthy, you know, between 15 to 35%.
And, and remember, the higher the utilization,
the more the cost optimization
for you. So really, the, the
key aspect here is the utilization is baked
in. And
now around an hour into the load test, you
see the traffic is still steady state, increasing but
steady state.
There's throttles, 932 throttles
to be exact,
but again, throttles are good, you know, we can handle it
in our code by way of retries or queuing or
so on, but there's not a single error.
The error rate is still 0.
We've scaled up to 21 instances
now, and if you observe carefully,
the scale up and scale down has both
been triggered.
Uh, it sort of tracks the
CPU utilization of the capacity provider,
and we're still at around 25% utilization,
22.5% in this case to be exact.
So I let the load tests
run for around 90 minutes.
And here's a key result I wanted to highlight.
So when we talk to customers, a
bunch of customers tell us that, hey, they take
this technical debt when they provision
for peak, when the workload profile shifts.
And when they take this technical debt, they don't apply
the scaling policies properly or they don't
spend time in optimizing it,
you know, they achieve low utilization rates.
So at around about 6% utilization rate,
the, the, my synthetic workload, you know, the load
test would have cost me $8.5
but if I improve it to 9%, you know, manually,
it would be $5.67.
But with lambda managed instances or LMI,
the auto-scaling is actually built in.
You, you actively have to go in and
choose to turn the auto scaling off, so from the
get-go, you're optimized,
and at the lower end of the scale we're able to achieve
around about 25% optimization off
the bat. This is literally a 60 to 90 minute
test, and in 130 minutes
itself, you, you could see earlier that the
utilization had reached 28.5%.
So, with that utilization,
you know, my costs just for the EC-2
would have been $2.05.
Now, on top of this,
Lambda managed instances applies a
management fee of around 15%
for EC2 instances.
Now, in that 15%, think about
what are you're getting.
You know, it's uh automatic scaling, you know, provisioning,
patching, continuous optimizations
based on your workload profile shifting.
There is literally no need for you to rearchitect
the solution away from lambda.
So you're saving all of that time.
You have to continue to use the same CICD
pipelines, the same observatory
tool set, and the same integrations are all available.
So, some key takeaways here,
uh, with lambda managed instances, you know, the
mental model again is to give you the simplicity
of lambda and serverless
with the specificity and the flexibility that
ECT gives to you.
And it is simple to maintain,
you know, out of, let's say, the 5 functions that
make up your application, you know, 4
require scale to 0, you can leave them
where they are.
The one that has achieved steady state or has
a different workload profile,
CPU intensive, you can move to
lambda's managed instances.
We continuously optimize the utilization
for you to give you the benefit of costs.
There is zero infrastructure management here,
and with the new
functionality of configuring CPU to
memory ratio, you know, you're able to bring in much
more workloads that you were not able to
run on serverless very easily.
And the managed instances, it just works.
Usman was talking about the ilities,
as he calls it earlier, you know, the reliability,
patching, you know, scalability,
availability, all of that, you know, AWS
and Lambda continues to be,
uh, responsible for
and all of this with the same developer experience
that you get with Lambda today
without having to rearchitect anything.
Next, we're gonna build a workflow-based architecture.
I'm gonna request Usman to come in, uh,
show how to build that,
and also talk a little bit about our strategy.
So, thank you very much.
All right thank you Janet.
Ah. No,
I, I think LMI does this or deserve a clap. It
I actually it was really, really cool. So a couple of cool, cool,
cool stories. I didn't do this in my rehearsal, so because
I would be mad at me.
The engineers were actually really mad at his demo.
I don't know if you guys saw what he was doing in this demo. He
was basically creating these spiky traffic,
1000 TPS for 1 2nd only.
And for those of you who operate the distributed
systems and uh scale distributed systems,
you know this is pretty much the worst workload. So the
engineers are like this is, we talk about synthetic workload.
This is as synthetic as it gets. But
again you can see the results of how the system, uh,
scales and works. Uh, it was a fun,
uh, fun last few weeks getting it out
the, out the door,
OK. And the second thing I wanted to connect with
you just to kind of connect to what I was speaking to you folks
at the beginning.
I I talked about trade-offs.
I talked about observability. I talked about
control. I talked about, um,
evolutionary architectures and how you have to use
ISC. Let's talk about where we are
with the trade-offs now with the, with the, with, with
what Judang just talked about. And then I'm gonna
show you a couple more things here
that we just recently launched. This was launched on Tuesday.
What I'm about to show you,
um, so
one of the, one in the picture, if you, for
those of you who remember the picture I showed about that FEMA
or res emergency response
application. What was the, what was the, what was the
challenging thing about it?
Your, your application now is highly
evolutionary single responsibility.
You don't have monoliths.
You're using infrastructure as code. And then what
Jane showed you with, with the power
of AI, uh,
actually generating SAM with the best serverless
practices pulled in is taking that
trade-off away. One of the hard, I mean for me personally
as a developer, I, I've shared with you folks, I, I
used to be a video game programmer, a hardcore C++
developer.
Writing YAL was always hard. It's
still always hard. I don't know why I can't do it, but
no, no, I don't have to do it.
I actually get really, really, really awesome
results from our MCP server with the best practices
built in. So that's one problem taken away
from developers and from infrastructure developers.
Second, uh, problem, and we, and
I, I'll be again very direct and forthright with you,
people used to say, Hey, lambda is too expensive at scale.
If my idea ever got big,
I will hate it or my boss will hate it if I'm an engineer
like because the costs go high.
And I was Jenakaki showed you with LMI
how we're able to deliver incredible usage
and look folks, I, I shared with you that I, I used to
run auto scaling. I've created hundreds of auto scaling
groups in, in my time at AWS.
I don't think I've ever managed to run code on those auto scaling
groups simply because I was just testing the service.
This is where I can go from infrastructure to code
to highly utilized code
literally in, in. In a couple of minutes
and that is, that is the most incredible thing about LMI.
So almost two fundamental things about
Serverless which was like, hey, it's expensive at scale,
or my, if I have to, I, uh, my idea gets
big, I have to rearchitect or I
have to deal with ISC and that's complex.
We've actually tackled those things, uh, really,
really well this year.
Now let's talk about a third thing which is,
hey, lambda doesn't run long run running
workflows or rather long running jobs, and if I ever,
uh, have this long running issue, I'll hit in a 15
minute timeout
and again I really hate my life.
So let's talk about workflows now and look folks, I've been
with the workflow services for a long time. Auto scaling
was one of the, is still one of the largest
users of simple workflow, so a little bit
behind the scenes.
Um,
I, I've, I own Simple Workflow as well. I, I'm
the engineering leader for Simple Workflow too.
One of the things we talked about, we've been talking to customers,
at least I've been talking to customers about workflow for
workflows for 12 years. Developers
just didn't get it unless you worked at Amazon, obviously,
because then we really get it,
uh, internally we, we know when you wanna
do reliable distributor systems you need a workflow.
The thing that has really brought workflows back
front and center, not everyone wants to talk about workflows,
obviously is AI agents or AI-based
workflows.
Um, so you obviously there's a ton of
interest in this, but look, this is, this is the system
we're building,
uh, and, and why we wanna do this is because orchestration
is important in the type of
applications, the new type of applications customers are building,
right? So in, in this particular, particular case I'm
talking about an enhancement to the, the
thing that, that Jenna kicked off
where I wanna be able to summarize the note from our
no note taking application. So these are some of the steps,
right? You'll have to retrieve the note from the storage
space. I think in my example is Dynamo DB.
You need to have, I, I mean, here's the thing with LLMs
they are asynchronous. You are waiting
for, for a response from them, and if you wanna scale
your LLM,
you have to make it more, more asynchronous versus
everything is synchronous around it.
Um, you, you generate the summary and
you need to store the result. Those are your steps
that quite literally map into a workflow,
right? And look, if
you were to write code today, you can run this code on anything,
EC2, any, any compute,
we can run this code on lambda as, as it is
right now.
You are now responsible for the reliability
of all these steps.
If, if you're not using a workflow system, you
are responsible for figuring out, OK,
when to handle retries,
when to roll back things
if things have gone, gone, gone incorrect, and
you can see,
you know, I have manual checkpointing
here somewhere. I don't have the line numbers unfortunately,
and I'm doing a bunch of sleeps and weights and
while you're waiting, especially if you're waiting on lambda.
You're paying for the compute
Right, OK, so what we heard
from developers basically was, look, I,
I, I don't wanna write code this way,
even if I, if I, it's simple,
AI can write this code for me really simply.
I don't wanna write this code myself and make it figure
out how to do it reliably.
Obviously I wanna still just still write code
and I wanna use my tools and ID.
Um, pausing and resuming is a really
powerful step simply
because if you, if you look at the most powerful use
of AI today.
It's basically AI code generation and guess
who who where the human is in the loop? It's, it's
uh, it's you guys, it's the developers
and so it's super powerful to be able to pause a
workflow and then resume it,
um, and finally I wanna use
my favorite programming languages and so look,
we, we heard you and now we're introducing
lambda durable functions or our Matt already
introduced it and so our lambda durable functions that you do
is you just simply write code. You write simple
sequential code. Well, all code is sequential.
Uh, and
reliability is baked in reliability
retries
your workflow semantics are just baked in.
Um, right now we support Node and
Python. You know, more languages are coming, as I
said, the team pushed super hard to get this out for reinvent
more language languages support obviously is coming,
uh, but Python and, and Node are super popular
with Lambda, and we, we covered both the most common
languages there.
Yes, you can suspend and resume long running
operations, and while you're suspending the operation,
you're not paying for lambda at all,
um, and finally.
It's all the, the, the beauty of managing
the elities. It's still lambda. And so,
yes, you know, you, some of you might have heard of durable executions
or, or, or workflows before.
What, what this is super unique is that this
is a compute service lambda
with that reliable workflow stuff
built right in. There's nothing else. You're simply
going to write a lambda function and I'm gonna show you
what that looks like.
OK, so in a durable, what durable functions
really how what behind the scenes durable functions do
is they come up with, come with a very simple SDK. If
you choose to, and I'll show you how to do it, if you
choose a durable function in the lambda console,
the SDK is loaded as part of the runtime for you.
Um,
they have the ability to checkpoint.
Uh, you decide when to checkpoint. By the way, this
all the system is built on top of the same underlying
system that powers step functions as well. For those of you who
are familiar with step functions,
a lot of these things will make, make a lot of sense
to you immediately,
um.
The you can checkpoint and step functions. Every
state is checkpointed then in this particular case
you're writing the code and you decide when to checkpoint
and then replay.
The idea behind replay is if you're waiting
or you're resuming your function
or um you know there's a failure
and then you wanna retry and replay from failure because
that's where reliability comes in.
You do not have to replay all the stuff that
was already checkpointed. You simply get
those results back so you're not ever wasting
compute. And so tying it
back to what I was saying about long running workflows, we
really thought long and hard about LMI as well,
and we said, hey, should we allow customers, I mean they're
already paying for the full EC2 instance, should we just allow them
to run lambda functions for hours.
But the whole point of doing that is that you're building
inherently unreliable software
if you're gonna do that. So we said, hey, can we do something better?
And that's how we got, got, got together with
the step functions teams and the teams collaborated
together to build a, a joint capability inside lambda.
So look, these are the durable, these are the things that make something
durable execution.
So getting started is simple,
you know, you choose a function name, but you know you're providing
an optional durable configuration. That's how
you turn it on.
Uh, you mean execution timeout and the retention
periods are have defaults, so all you're doing
is basically saying I wanna do, I want this function
to be durably config configured.
And look, I'm gonna actually show you what a running
function will look like. So I've, I've already created one of these
functions. So what, what they come up with is,
is they have a new tab on the console called durable executions.
And again, for those of you familiar with step functions, you'll
be, you're used to the observability of
the workflow. We've taken a lot of things.
So I'm gonna kick off my durable, durable function.
Don't worry, I'll walk you through the code in a second.
And you'll see
that there's a new execution that has started,
and we'll click into that in a second.
Uh, and you'll, you'll see that the steps are
described where, where the, you know, the, the
system and the workflow has already fetched the,
the,
the note,
it's starting to process it. It's starting
to then send it to the LLM for a summarization,
and you can actually kind of see the progress. I mean, in, in
my demo here, obviously there's no failures, but if
anything was being retried, you'll be able to quickly
pinpoint where your asynchronous task.
Is not behaving the right way
and look there you go,
everything is done and so these workflows can run run up
to 1 year obviously the most canonical
use cases short lived transactions which are
probably under under sometimes under 1 2nd,
sometimes a few minutes,
but these you, you absolutely can build
human in the loop systems here as well which
cover which can which can last a long
time. So let's take a look at what the actual code was. Let's
zoom in. So the first thing I wanted to highlight
again for many of the developers who are familiar with lambda.
You'll see that you know lambda has a context object.
When you create a durable function, you get a durable context
object, and the durable context object has
those things I talk to you about which is enable you
to do waiting for for or checkpointing,
which is a step, and it has structured logging
as well for observability to see where you
are while the workflow is running.
Um,
the durability part, uh, is, is
again baked in, so I'm gonna actually show you this is the,
the, the step for actually retrieving
the note
from, from Dynamo DB in this particular
case. So the code you're writing is, is, is
basically the, the step which comes from the
context object.
Um,
the Dynamo DB cos we go to get item
command right there,
and then you have that structured logging to actually, you know, in
the console or any, any of of
your observability tools where you're sending your logs
to from your lambda functions,
you can actually see, hey, what was actually done right
now one of the coolest things about step
functions or workflows in general is is item potency.
Item potency is super important when you do transactions.
You item potency enables you to like basically have
one workflow, one unique workflow of a type,
and not allow a second version of instance of the workflow
to get started.
So that's through the name of the durable
context when you start the durable,
durable function, and you give it a name,
uh, or, or, or an ID when it gets
started, you're able to kind of
maintain that consistency. So no two objects
are working on the same thing.
Um, so super powerful
use case for, for a ton of, uh,
uh, a ton of applications.
And finally I wanted to highlight weight. Weighting is as simple
as just calling context of weight.
And while you're waiting we shut down the execution
environment so you're no longer paying for it
and once whatever you're waiting for either resumes
I'm I'm, I use a very simple code which which is
basically a wait
you can actually do call back you can do a
callback with condition where where you know
you are able to
wait for some condition to be true and then the execution
environment wakes up
all of these things basically allow you to save time
while while you're waiting and you're
not paying for any computer and you're not paying for any resources
at that time.
Um, and then the workflow starts
from exactly that, that same step
after the weight is complete
and look, in the previous example there was a
bunch of steps I, I gave you. I, I
kind of quickly walked through the code what would it take
to actually build such a workflow, but for
the developers here and the engineering managers who
review the architecture for the developers,
you can imagine with what, what would it take to
in a traditional architecture to build something like
this. You're using cues.
You're using,
you know, compute all over the place at different
steps between the queues because now you're not bundling
things properly.
Your deployments are more complex, complex. Debugging
is more complex. If anything goes wrong, replayability,
rehydration, all the some of the, some of the basic
challenges of a distributed event driven architecture
come in. But with a simple orchestration, a
simple deployment, a simple STLC,
you're able to basically build really, really
reliable workflows. And again, as I said, there
is no real comparison to this, this
technology. Uh, out there there's lots of workflow technologies
out there. This is actually a compute
technology with work workflows built into it. And
so look, we've got long running work of, uh, lambda
functions now that can run up to a year.
Um,
so anyway, I covered these points already, um,
and so we can get going,
all right, so we, we talked about our
MCP server and what we're doing with Gen AI
development. There was a whole bunch of things we've done like, uh,
how many of you, by the way, have installed our,
um, our actual dev tools
for VS code.
Few people
Awesome,
um, look, I would highly recommend
for the developers here to go try to check out our developer
tools or from the AWS tool kit. I'm assuming most
of you use VS code.
Um, one of the things you might have missed, for example,
is you're not able to remotely debug, uh,
lambda function. You can actually put a breakpoint into our
running lambda function through our tools as well. So we really,
really are focusing on developer experience.
But, um,
look, Jenna already talked about MCP and how that
makes developer experience super easy, especially on ISC
and our best practicetresses. We talked about LMI,
which lets you run long lived workflow, uh,
sorry, steady state,
large workloads at incredible, uh,
discounts and, uh, and choice
of EC2 instances, and I talked about, uh,
durable functions for you folks as well where you can now
run really reliable because reliability
and durability is super key for long run running workloads
because it's not a question of.
If you'll have an infrastructure issue, it's when you'll have
an infrastructure issue.
So, um, but we're not done.
I do. I wanna talk to you about one more thing we launched
a week or so before we invent
this is really around, uh, especially security
sensitive SAS applications.
So here's a, a scenario.
You have 3 customers or let's say 3
tenants of your SAS,
um, and you're using lambda. Lambda has,
uh, you know, maybe you're using a global variable in the lambda
function. Maybe,
maybe you have some, some, something in the temp file
you're using our temp storage.
Um,
maybe you wanna restrict and you wanna say, hey,
uh, an execution or invocation to this lambda
function should only talk to the Dynamo
DB table
and only fetch data from the Dynamo D table DB DB table row
for this customer who's calling or invoking this function.
Um, so in this case I have a blue tenant
and, you know, they created a lambda function, we
created an execution environment for them and maybe
there's something left over, maybe there's some global variables
left over,
and then the yellow tenant calls.
But the problem with the yellow tenant is they, they might have
some side effects that they leave in the lambda function as
well, um, or,
uh, you, you, uh, you're not, you're not not
able to isolate those iso uh,
those side effects, uh, if you've written code this way.
And finally, of course, you have a green tenant,
and again
the request is being, being sent to maybe the
same execution environment, and there's some side effects.
And look, this is nothing lambda specific here, right?
This is true for any computer you you
run. You can do you see two instances
containers.
Um, one of the hardest challenges is
how do I isolate my customers from each other
without actually creating individual infrastructure
for each customer.
So something pretty expensive to do, you can do it.
Uh, the way you do it on lambda traditionally before this
feature is you would create a lambda function per customer.
I know it sounds ridiculous, but
there's customers and use cases with that
where you have to do that. Well,
now you don't,
uh, so a coup,
a week or so ago we launched tenant isolation, and
what that does is that in the invocation, so it's
still the same lambda function you're writing,
you pass a tenant ID.
And then what we do is we create
individual execution environments which are not
shared by any of the tenants for
you. And the idea behind this is
that if you have sensitive software, if you have AI
generated software, you have, you're,
you're in an environment where you really
wanna even isolate your own customers from your
infrastructure
now you can do that and it's super, super
simple, no extra infrastructure to manage, no, not
even extra lambda functions to manage.
OK, so we're almost through,
and I know I, uh, we have a little bit of time, so
I'd love to, uh, invite Jonah up as well and take
some of your questions as well,
but I wanted to kind of share with you kind of what is our
strategy because we're not done yet. I, you know, I,
I'll, I always like leaking a few things,
and you know we've got some big things done by Reinvent.
I suspect in the next 6 months we have some other
big things we're working on that didn't quite make it,
so keep your ears and eyes peeled for more
information, I think, but all those things will be in the
same in this team.
Lambda has always been about developers. Lambda
has always been about, about speed, and we
really embrace that idea.
What we're trying to do is we're trying to get the objections
out of the way.
Like objections from platform teams that it can get
too expensive, objections from our ISC
is really hard to get right.
Um, are the fundamentals like, hey, can I
really do cost control with lambda really, really well?
All of those things are gonna be built in and
we're really, really laser focusing
on, on developers and how developers
can move fast with services. So like with this we
were, we over the last 18 months I talked about remote
debugging and, and some of the stuff we didn't even show you.
We are heavily involved in the dev tool space
to make sure that serverless development, you don't
have to be a serverless developer, you just have to be a
developer
to get the the benefits out of it.
Alright, so just to recap
the whole thing again,
we, we have a mirror road map that you can see
that's focusing on developer experience and then the fundamentals
are there.
What's coming up next is observability
hotel support. We've heard from customers.
We wanted to have like a native hotel support. We've
already done a bunch of launches over the last few years around
structured logging and getting lambda
to be ready for a hotel, but we wanna have full hotel support for customers.
Um, that's a key part. It's a key trade-off that
I mentioned in an evolutionary architecture, so
we wanna continue to make our observability better,
um, more runtime, uh, again you
might have missed this, but we just launched, uh, Rust
support in lambda as well now, uh, that was,
uh, I think a week or so ago as well, but more languages,
more frameworks, more runtime are coming.
Um,
look, with LMI, with durable functions,
we are able to now, uh, open up a
whole new class of applications that you just couldn't use
on, on lambda, but we're not again done.
There's so much more we wanna do because
we, we believe customers shouldn't have to choose
to, to manage a lot, a lot of those ilities that
I was talking about earlier simply because
they have a business need that doesn't fit,
um. And look, integrations
are bread and butter. The way lambda delivers that
speed is that so many things from
EventBridge to SNS to API gateway
to ALBs to SQS to Kafka,
they're all just built in. You're not trying to
figure out how do I make this technology work with my
code. They're all just built in and it's our
responsibility to make in. We're gonna continue to
do more both on the dev tool site and
an integration site so that your favorite, like,
you know, uh,
CICD tools, your favorite observability
tools just work with lambda.
And look, you might also not know this, but we just recently,
again just right before we invent, so Janek and the product team
were quite busy.
We, we launched our roadmap as well
publicly. So if you were to just to
take a look at the QR code, that would take you to the,
to the road map as well. Give us feedback. We
love to hear from you.
Uh, I'm gonna invite Jenna over. Janek, we have a
a few more minutes. Um, thank you
so much, folks for sticking around and coming out on Thursday.
If there's some questions, we'd love to take them. Thank you.
Thank you.